packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
now it's all about cooking with chili
[Music]
for me chilies are an incredible
ingredient in The Cook's Arsenal capable
of transforming dishes adding excitement
heat and a wonderful taste I'm going to
show you how to get to grips with their
intense flavor first up
red mullet with sweet chili sauce
cooking is about being adventurous and
having the confidence to go off peace
and being a little bit more daring so
when you start combining peanuts chili
flakes and this amazing fish red mullet
trust me you're in for an amazing treat
we're going to make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce
first off your chili off with the top in
half
on those seeds inside are very powerful
incredibly hot
but full of flavor garlic
two cloves of garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin so it
helps the puree
chilies in the pesto mortar garlic in
salt and it will touch
sugar
and
and then start grinding
push down first
[Music]
salt and the sugar
really helps to puree the chili and the
garlic
fish sauce always a base
to a chili sauce two tablespoons in
a touch of rice wine vinegar
fish sauce gives it the saltiness the
vinegar gives it a nice acidic wake up
three tablespoons
of olive oil
nice
mix that up beautiful look at the colors
incredible now spring onions I want the
texture
and the crunch spring onions in
the coriander slice it once
in
fresh lime
and that goes brilliantly with the red
mullet just really wakes up the chili
the garlic and reminds the sauce that
we're serving with fish now taste
hmm
it's delicious look at that
beautiful
the longer that chili sauce sits there
the better it gets now for the peanuts
and chili that's going to coat the top
of the red mullet
peanuts in
salt
in that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes creates a nice sort of warm heat
I'm using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating which
will really crunch up when cooking just
a little bit of the coriander
mix the coriander in to the peanuts and
look I like them quite textured I don't
want them too small as a powder
otherwise they'll burn but Crush lightly
to coat the fish with the chili and
peanut seasoning in a separate Bowl beat
two eggs along with a splash of fish
sauce
take your fillet
lay in your red money
dip it in shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down
cover that red Monet
oh beautiful
now make sure that Pan's really nice and
piping hot if you put the fish in and
the Pan's cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chili
just going to slide off the fish so we
need to sear it in and get it nice and
crisp in and lay away from you
peaceful
[Music]
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot get your olive oil
and just Place Another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up as it hits the center and it
really helps to stay so much more in
control
and turn
nice and gently
you want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed crispness
which adds A really lovely flavor
tilt the pan and just baste
the top of the red mullet with a really
nice piping hot olive oil you've got
that really nice roasted Crunch and it
goes brilliantly with that soft
sweetness of that fish inside gas off
and just leave them sitting in there
and finish with lime and just go over
each one
now and take them out
in the sauce touch on the bottom and the
tail of each fish
now to round that off serving some
fragrant rice
sauteed broccoli
amazing and there you have a delicious
peanut and crusted red mullet with a
wonderful sweet chili sauce cooking with
chilies isn't all about blow your head
off heat this dish uses the exciting
Taste of a chili but has a deliciously
elegant and subtle flavor
as you become more confident using
chilies you'll find they can transform
your cooking chilies are a great way of
making dishes exciting and vibrant here
are three quick recipes that are full of
flavor and come with a kick
first up pasta with tomatoes and
cherries and chilies
[Music]
for the spicy sauce slice Anchovies and
garlic
next dried chilies it's great for
keeping the cupboard to add a hit of
heat on demand
[Music]
add the anchovy all to a hot pan and Fry
the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes
chopped black olives and salty Capers
cook to combine the flavors
in a separate pan boil dry spaghetti
another great store cupboard staple
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain add to the sauce with a splash of
the water it's full of starch which
gives a great silky consistency
then season with pepper and top with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes pasta with tomatoes
anchovy and chilies
my next deliciously different chili
recipe is grilled corn with Chipotle
chili butter
[Music]
first the topping chopped coriander
then add softened butter
soaked Chipotle chilies in hot water
these are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing Smoky flavor
[Music]
drain and chop
mixed together and seasoned
[Music]
next fry corn on the cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when colored add water to steam through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over Lancashire cheese
to eat grilled corn with Chipotle chili
butter and utterly delicious Smoky treat
my final recipe is a chili classic
jerk chicken
[Music]
start by making the intense jerk
marinade first Scotch bonnet chilies
they may be small but pack real heat and
a fruity punch
then chop garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves cinnamon
nutmeg
and allspice
[Music]
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
[Music]
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
add olive oil to a hot dish
Brown the marinated chicken for 10
minutes
then add Worcestershire sauce
[Music]
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
Finger Licking Good
three different chilies three amazing
flavors
three irresistible dishes
nice
next five more of my 100 tips that'll
make your life easier in the kitchen
first up how to de-seed chili to get the
seeds out hold it upright and just rub
the chili between your hands the seeds
are incredibly hot we're just releasing
them from the inside
tapping it down
and then again just a final little rub
now cut the top off and then
just open up
and look
they come out like little miniature
Smarties
and there
got the little bottom bit off
amazing
next a great tip for using spare chilies
using string tie together the stalks
then simply hang in your kitchen in just
a few weeks you'll get your very own
dried chilies great crumbled into dishes
for adding heat on demand chilies are
surprisingly versatile if you love them
in Savory dishes my tip is to try adding
them to melted chocolate ganache for
chocolate chili truffles or sprinkled
over fresh fruit like mango or
watermelon a great tip to prevent
burning sensitive skin when working with
chilies to get rid of that spice and
that heat on your fingers a little bit
of lemon squeeze a little bit of lemon
juice and that instantly gets rid of the
heat fresh lemon juice
spice up your drinks for a Mexican twist
add a dash of hot chili sauce to beer or
using cocktails to give your drink a
very different sort of Kick this is my
ultimate cookery course 100 recipes to
stay your life on I'll be showing you an
amazing spicy beef salad take a little
teaspoon from your dressing just go over
the leaf but first The Secret of cooking
fantastic food is to start with great
ingredients the more you know personally
about where your ingredients are from
and how they produce the better so don't
be scared ask lots of questions and
learn and when it comes to chilies
there's no one better to ask than chili
grower Joanna Plum who's been farming
chillies from mild to mind blown for
over 11 years I eat chilies all the time
every single day she grows over 60 Types
on her farm and really knows her
poblanos from a habaneros
actually it's about Flavor as well some
are sweet some are aromatic and they can
be used in so many different dishes when
you go shopping and you're looking for a
chili what should you be looking for
what you want to do is look at the chili
and it needs to be nice and firm and
glossy generally the bigger the chili
the milder it's going to be the smaller
the chili the hotter and if it's small
and wrinkly like this one it's going to
blur your socks off another way to tell
if a chili is hot or not is to split it
open and smell it if it's a super hot
chili it'll clear sinuses
the heat of a chili comes from an oil
called capsaicin and that is
concentrated mainly at the top of the
chili where the seeds are now when
you're cooking with a chili and you want
the flavor of the chili but not too much
of the heat start with just using the
bottom of it as you get closer to the
seeds that chili is going to get hotter
so if you remove the seeds that also
does remove some of the heat there's
thousands of varieties out there because
they cross pollinate very very easily
and that's why the world's hottest chili
is always changing
Joanna's right with over 200 types
available all with different flavors
Aromas and of course levels of heat it's
important to buy what you like here are
my top chilies whatever your desired
kick
at the mild end poblano these are great
for stuffing have a delicate flavor and
often used in Mexican dishes
starting to get hot the jalapeno when
they're green they're like spicy bell
pepper the redder they are the sweeter
they are bird's eye where they really
start to pack a punch long thin and
pungent they're great in Thai Dishes and
are often green or red and at the top
end the habanero these Lantern shaped
demons have a delicious fruity taste and
then the firecracker of the chili World
another way to use chilies is to smoke
them and to make chipotle what it is
it's just a Mesquite smoked red jalapeno
it smells fantastic you can almost get
that like Smoky bacon sort of flavor out
of it so you would use this and anything
that you would slow cook so you're
eating a chili and it's really too hot
for you the best way to get rid of that
heat is to drink some milk or a dairy
product like yogurt whatever you do
don't go for water or for beer don't be
frightened of trying new types of
chilies in your cooking experimenting
with these amazing fiery beasts is a
great excuse for getting hot-headed in
the kitchen they give you a natural high
much like when you've been exercising so
your endorphins are released and you
just feel good chilies make you happy
and they're also an aphrodisiac
Southeast Asian Chefs they're brilliant
at balancing the hot spices of chili
with sweet sour and salty flavors
if you want a new Twist on a favorite
dish spice it up with chili
my next recipe is super simple to make
but have wonderful depth and complexity
of flavors spicy beef salad
chillies if you use them confidently
they can really add a new dimension to
the style of cooking but the real trick
is finding that balance of flavors that
really suits you because that's the most
important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this is cooking
it quickly season the steaks generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the sirloin
take the sirloin out of the fridge
literally 20 minutes before you want to
cook them so it gets up to room
temperature they cook more evenly but
more importantly you can actually season
right inside the steak this little bit
of fat down here season that as well
because that is what we want to roast
and get that really nice and rendered
olive oil in a tablespoon
roll that round
as it starts to smoke in with the stakes
into the pan
and lay away again into the pan and lay
away if you don't hear that noise the
minute those steaks hit the pan don't
put them in so the secret now is getting
that color on the steak turning it once
and once only and cooking it for two and
a half minutes each side what I want to
do is to get that bit of fat rendered so
it adds a lot more flavor just hold the
steak down like that and that starts to
melt the fat which makes it so much more
tender there should be no white fat left
anywhere
turn them over
really important to have that steak up
to room temperature before you start
cooking it so the inside is nice and
warm so he spends less time in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important
now two fingers touch
it goes in it says rare I'm happy for
them to be rare Because by the time I
let them rest
I'm going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking out onto a plate
and let them rest
one
one two
let's get my juices over
foreign
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of a chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands and tapping
until the seeds fall out cut it in half
and just chop it
in
garlic and chili Works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it to get your
knife
and just slam it down pops out very very
quickly in a little touch of salt
rub
stop going around in circles first
you'll see it purring
nice clear that off
now we've got the heat in there from the
chili and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effect
fish sauce fresh lime this is a simple
fresh chili dressing and it was
something I fell in love with in Vietnam
and Cambodia because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve the
sugar quick taste
wow right vegetables great fuss-free way
to get super thin ribbons of carrot is
to use a veg peeler
when they're that thin they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
[Music]
lovely given the dimensions of the salad
I'm use a banana shallot they are
incredibly mellow
very sweet
across
chop up
the shallot
and mix that through I want some
Sweetness in there now little Vine
Tomatoes slice them
in half tomatoes in shallot radish
carrots and tomatoes next peel and slice
cucumber chopped spring onions and Shred
baby gem lettuce and then finally get
some fresh mint it's young mint so you
don't need to take all those stalks off
all you do is hold a bunch upside down
and then take it for a little trim
and just chop that once through
look at that nice minted salad a couple
of tablespoons of dressing don't flood
the salad with the dressing you can
always add but we can't take it away now
really mix that dressing in there make
sure all that chili and garlic and palm
sugar wraps around that salad beautiful
foreign
rested it's now nice and medium rare a
little bit of fat we don't want to find
that in the salad just slice that off
that serves its purpose
kept that steak nice and moist
slice going with the grain it's almost
like slicing through butter and look
inside
beautiful pink if you slice the beef too
thinly then it goes Stone Cold and more
importantly all the goodness runs out of
it nice thick slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
the rest of your salad
dip that on top and finish it off with
some toasted peanuts peanuts in
now there's nuts are really toasted nuts
on
get another pan and just
a crush
was it cool down
just run them through with a knife
you can hear how crunch they are another
texture under the taste of the salad
and then from there sprinkle
and finally take that
just finish it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce and there is
one tasty very well textured spicy beef
salad
[Music]
right this is my guide to cooking with
spice
adding big gutsy flavors using spices at
the beginning of cooking and then simply
letting the dish slow cook is a
brilliant way of getting maximum flavor
with minimum effort
first recipe melts in the mouth and
because the oven does most of the work
it's a cinch to make slow cooked fiery
lamb cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it Cooks the more flavor some it
becomes
marinating the lamb first chillers we're
going to use a mixture of red and green
take off the tops
and just slice
in garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just get it in there cooking for up
to three hours
everything sort of Blends and almost
sort of
pures itself together
smoke paprika it goes brilliantly well
with the chilies two teaspoons in a
touch of dried oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out is
extraordinary they release a little oil
as well it helps to tenderize the lamb
Touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb Chomp in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious vegetables carrots and
onions and that's it sliced
cigarette slicing vegetables for
braising is not getting too thin you
slice the onions too thin they burn
you've got that horrible Char taste on
that slow braised braising it's just a
chef's term that means cooking in liquid
on a low heat making the meat incredibly
moist and beautifully tender so the
secret of braising is having a really
nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
Touch of olive oil
lemon hold the bone because you're in
control then into the pan
you want that white fat to start
rendering so it'll add more fat
therefore making it a lot more
flavoursome as it braises
Chillers
cinnamon
in mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're going
to color on the lamb which washes off as
it braises in the oven so be generous
with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of Baileys
so now you lift the lamb up
and get the lamb
sat on top of the vegetables
now the glaze the pan with red wine
the glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
it can really transform that dish always
delays then bring to the boil and cook
for about 10 minutes to reduce the wines
reduced down by half now for the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
I slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouth-wateringly tender now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and gravy tender grab it by the
the shank rolling around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce nice
beautiful just get some mint don't chop
it pick that fresh mint and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting in the mouth lamb
shank amazing
[Music]
to get the most out of your spices
there's only one piece of kit that you
need pestle and mortar I mean they look
fantastic and it's essential for any
good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pestos
to dressings and cost them around 15
quid
used to grind spices and you'll max out
on Flavor get perfect textures and
always be totally in control make sure
you've got a nice large circumference of
the bowl
so you can grind away the heavier the
more durable they are the more
confidence it gives you when you're
pounding and there's almost a way of
confirming homemade hand pounded
grab yourself a pestle of mortar and
soon you'll be spicing with ease
[Music]
[Applause]
spices are a brilliant way to add an
extra layer and a depth of complexity to
any dish learning to use them properly
will really improve your cooking here
are three more of my super simple spice
recipes to get you going
[Applause]
[Music]
first up a very easy chili and spice
white bait
[Music]
start with the spice coating
toast Szechuan peppercorns and coriander
seeds in a hot dry pan to release their
flavors
[Music]
add chili flakes and grind the pestle
and mortar to make a fiery fine powder
combined with plain flour season and mix
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
[Music]
white bait on an oily fish that are
healthy delicious and cooking minutes
[Music]
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
[Music]
ready in under 10 minutes chili and
spice white bait and easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
but with my take on razal hanoud a
classic Moroccan spice blend
in a dry pan toast Cinnamon cloves
coriander fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
at paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus peel and chop butternut
squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped Ginger
drizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
[Music]
allowed to cool and place in a blender
at tahini a Nutty paste made from sesame
seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon
juice
and a drizzle of olive oil
flits into a luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus
my final deliciously spicy dishes
curry spice sweet corn soup
[Music]
first The Fragrant curry paste
roast coriander and cumin seeds until
aromatic
then grind adding crushed garlic chili
powder turmeric and finely chopped
Ginger
foreign
together with olive oil to form a thick
paste
for the soup fry finely chopped onions
in olive oil
[Music]
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors
add cubed potatoes
chicken stock
and season
when the potato has softened stir in
creamed corn
[Music]
then add whole sweet corn kernels with
some of the juices
and transfer to a blender and Blitz
until smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
[Music]
and it's ready to serve
wonderfully satisfying curried spiced
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch
three more stunning recipes that make
cooking with spice simple
incredible
[Music]
My ultimate cookery course
this is my guide to cooking with spice
next up my shopping guide to buying
spices
[Music]
when I buy my spice I only want the best
and it always pays to get expert advice
Burger has been selling every spice
Under the Sun in London's not a hill for
over 20 years so she really knows what
she's talking about I love spices to
smell the texture the color spices are
so versatile something very very simple
can be really transformed into something
really delicious with thousands of
aromatic ingredients on a shelf if it
smells good she sells it if you're
buying spices buy them whole then you
can try roast them grind them when you
need them and then they will release the
essential oils whole spices you can keep
for years give them a good bushing wine
bottle with your rolling pin or whatever
and you see there is still Aroma and you
can taste it you smell it then it's fine
there's four main spices one is sweet
one is sour one is bitter and one is hot
this is cinnamon and that is really a
great example of a sweet spice when you
buy cinnamon quill like this you have to
check that you have loads of different
layers in here then you can either grind
this or you'd break a piece off I mean
this doesn't smell of anything now
but if you roll it in your hand just
quickly like this
and then you smell it again this is just
unbelievable if you have spaghetti
bolognese put a pinch of cinnamon in it
to bring out the flavor
this is one of those
really special spices sour like a lemon
but it has a salty aftertaste I use this
anywhere for marinades to salad you
haven't lived unless you tried it a
great example for a bitter spice would
actually be a turmeric this is actually
a root it grows in the ground like
ginger use it very very sparingly about
that much well actually color you a
curry or a rice dish wonderful yellow
watch your fingers you get really yellow
fingers from it and then we come to the
hot spices one spice that I couldn't
miss and that is Hungarian paprika
paprika is the powdery form of a bell
pepper what makes the Hungarian paprika
different is that they actually grow it
in Vineyards it's sort of between the
vines it has a sweetness and it has a
sharpness to it I have it in ice cream I
have it on fish I have it everywhere
Burgers spot on about the power of
spices to transform dishes whether
Savory or sweet here's my quick guide to
the spices I use most
[Music]
spice I couldn't do without always buy a
whole and grind yourself so you get the
freshest flavor
cardamom these pods come in green or
black types and have a fantastic Spicy
Sweet Taste brilliant for everything
from curries to rice dishes and puddings
coriander these citrusy seeds are
perfect whole in pickles or grind to use
in fragrant stews and soups
Savory Spice that's pungent and nutty
it's great in marinade for delicious
Meat and Fish
then cinnamon sweetly fragrant and great
with apples or in cakes
and Nutmeg warm and spicy it's delicious
and a vegetable sauce finely saffron
these sweet strands Infuse a brilliant
bright red color and are great in
risottos and even though it's more
expensive than gold a pinch goes a long
long way
store your spices properly and they'll
last for years you keep it airtight in a
tin or in a glass chair in your cupboard
don't be scared of spices like an
aftershave or perfume you have to select
it yourself it has to fit in with your
taste and with your kitchen supermarkets
and good local shops sell an amazing
array of different spices so there's no
excuse for not being adventurous be bold
find what you like and spice up your
cooking
like all chefs I love the challenge of
transforming classic recipes giving them
a new twist to make them modern and
vibrant
keep old dishes fresh and exciting it's
great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored British
classic but with addition of spices it's
given a new lease of Life fragrant spice
rice pudding I love cooking with spices
but you don't have to just cook Savory
dishes using aromatics and spices across
desserts takes your puddings to a
completely different level
first off our spices this is a fresh
vanilla pod fragrant and packed full of
flavor use the back of the knife and
flatten it that removes all those little
seeds off the skin of the vanilla pod
take your knife slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible
take the tip of the knife and you scrape
inside and look all those seeds dying to
come out that is incredible there are
thousands of seeds still ingrained to
the Pod so put them in to the casserole
cardamom powerful spicy say two little
pods place your knife on top
lightly crack them cracking the cardamom
pods helps release all the amazing
flavor cloves because of that kind of
aniseed flavor with a lot of depth
one two three cinnamon stick
snap and in
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding is
going to taste of turn on the heat
lightly toast those spices just a couple
of seconds and what's going to happen is
just going to sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
an even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk in
sugar two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavors to infuse and that's why it's
pudding reminds me of my time in India
where I got really into that chai tea
fragrance because it was just so
delicious and so comforting
take a lime
in
the lime just cuts through the richness
of the coconut gives it that nice little
bit of acidity goes fantastically well
with the cinnamon and that fresh vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and in with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out three to
five minutes
boiling it rapidly the rice opens up and
it goes into mush we want to keep that
nice texture of that sort of fragrant
rice pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
I'm going to show you how I take this
simple delicious aromatic rice put into
a completely different level here's what
I do take two egg yolks separate them
now give that a really nice whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
whisk that into the egg yolks
[Music]
just as nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard turn off
the gas add that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked started to
go nice and soft you can just see how
it's opening up
but look it's like Rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally green more citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
a rice pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven 15 minutes at
200 degrees to finish cooking the rice
and develop the intensely aromatic
flavors
[Music]
look at that
an incredibly fragrant rice pudding how
beautiful does that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
I'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
[Music]
next my tricks of the trays and kitchen
tips
[Music]
[Applause]
first how to zest a lemon
the important part is not to zest any of
the pith watch the following technique
and I'll show you how
with all these original graters really
important when we use this is the fine
zester not the big rough one not the one
for slicing and not the other one for
grating this little one here onto a
plate because it's always easier to lift
off on the plate than it is of the board
and the most important thing about
zesting a lemon is nice long strokes but
twisting the lemon round every time we
go down we twist
same with the orange and same with the
lime
little tap
if you go too far let me just show you
look you've got that white bitter pith
that destroys the wonderful
zesty flavor and look that's what we're
looking for there this really nice
vibrant lemon zest delicious
garlic is a key ingredient in so many
spicy dishes my tip for finally chopping
a minson is add a pinch of salt for
abrasion which helps break the fibers of
the garlic down for a much better result
for getting the most out of root Ginger
simply remove the skin using a teaspoon
it's easier than using a knife and you
can get around the tricky bits or just
keep the skin on and give it a good wash
[Music]
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavor left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge
when grinding up spices if you have any
left over you can store in an airtight
jar for up to two months great for a
spicy kick to have at your fingertips
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
tips
and 100 recipes to stay your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the app store for details
go on get cooking